el objetivo de este vídeo es balancear
esta ecuación en nacido pero pues
tenemos que empezar notando que esta es
una reacción redox y vamos a empezar
asignando los estados de oxidación así
es que vamos a empezar por aquí con el
anio cndh y cromato el oxígeno sabemos
que tiene un estado de oxidación de
menos 2 y tenemos 7 oxígenos en esta
molécula entonces menos 2 por 7 nos da
un total de menos 14 menos 14
sabemos también que el total para el
anión de cromato es menos 2 jockey
porque esa es la carga de esta molécula
aquí tenemos que la carga de la unión de
cromato es menos 2 y entonces los cromos
en total nos tienen que aportar más 12
ahora en la molécula tenemos dos átomos
de cromo por lo que cada uno nos tiene
que aportar más 6
así es que el estado de oxidación del
cromo tiene que ser más 6 bueno ahora
vamos con el neón cloruro tiene una
carga menos 1 por lo que su estado de
oxidación es menos 1 el ión cromo por
aquélla tiene una carga más 3 por lo
cual su estado de oxidación es más 3 y
finalmente tenemos una molécula de cloro
por aquí cuyo estado de oxidación es 0
si nos ponemos a observar la oxidación y
reducción aquí el cloro pasó de un
estado de oxidación menos 1 a un estado
de oxidación 0 ok
aumentó su estado de oxidación perdió
electrones por lo tanto se trata de una
oxidación el cloro fue oxidado mientras
que el cromo pasó de un estado de
oxidación más 6
un estado de oxidación 3 eso significa
que se redujo su estado de oxidación por
lo tanto el cromo sufrió una reducción
aunque ella así es que estamos
comprobando que esta es una reacción
redox porque algunos átomos se están
oxidando mientras que otros átomos se
están reduciendo ahora si lo que
queremos es balancear esta reacción lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
escribir las semis reacciones
así es que vamos a partir esta reacción
en las 12 mi reacción es la semi
reacción de oxidación y la semi reacción
de reducción
a ver vamos a empezar teníamos por allí
nuestro a nyon cloruro el cual se
transformaba en una molécula de cloro y
lo que acabamos de ver hace unos minutos
es que esta es la semi reacción de
oxidación mientras que la semi reacción
de reducción involucraba el cromo
teníamos por aquí nuestro and john dee
cromato cr 2 o 72 - el cual se convierte
en cromo tres más ok
esta es la semi reacción de reducción
ese fue el primer paso escribir las semi
reacciones y ahora queremos balancear
los átomos que no sean oxígeno e
hidrógeno entonces en la semi reacción
de oxidación por aquí en los productos
tenemos un solo cloro mientras que en
los reactivos tenemos dos claros así es
que para balancear esta reacción tenemos
que poner un 2 por aquí
en la semi reacción de reducción pues
tenemos dos átomos de cromo el oxígeno
ahorita todavía no lo estamos
balanceando y en los productos tenemos
únicamente un átomo de cromo entonces
tenemos que poner por aquí un 2 y listo
paso número 3 balancea el oxígeno
agregando agua ok
observando la semi reacción de oxidación
vemos que no necesitamos hacer nada
porque no tenemos ningún oxígeno en esta
semi reacción sin embargo en la semi
reacción de reducción por aquí tenemos 7
oxígenos tenemos 7 oxígenos del lado de
los reactivos y ningún oxígeno del lado
de los productos entonces tenemos que
balancear esta semi reacción que tenemos
7 oxígenos del lado izquierdo y ninguno
del lado derecho y para balancear lo que
hacemos es agregar agua ok pero pues
queremos 7 oxígenos entonces agregamos 7
moléculas de agua
y listo ahora tenemos que balancear el
hidrógeno agregando protones aunque hay
agregando h más y voy a dibujar a estos
y ver o genos con rojo
en la semi reacción de oxidación podemos
ver nuevamente que no necesitamos hacer
nada porque no hay ningún hidrógeno sin
embargo en la semi reacción de reducción
para balancear los átomos de oxígeno
agregamos agua y por lo tanto agregamos
hidrógenos y ahora tenemos 7 por 214
hidrógenos del lado de los productos del
lado derecho y ningún hidrógeno del lado
izquierdo
entonces para balancear esta reacción lo
que tenemos que hacer es agregar 14
protones
y listo y ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es balancear las cargas agregando
electrones pero pues vamos a hacer más
espacio nuclear y ahora tenemos que
balancear las cargas agregando
electrones pero pues para eso tenemos
que ver cómo están las cargas vamos a
empezar por la semi reacción de
oxidación ok empezamos por aquí con el
año el cloruro el a nyon cloruro tiene
una carga negativa -1 pero hay dos de
estos aviones cloruro entonces en total
tenemos una carga menos 2 ojo este no es
el estado de oxidación esta es
simplemente la carga y muchas personas
suelen confundirse en este punto por el
lado de los productos tenemos una
molécula de cloro que no tiene carga y
entonces tenemos una carga menos 2 del
lado izquierdo y una carga 0 del lado
derecho entonces tenemos dos cargas
negativas del lado izquierdo
y ninguna carga del lado derecho y
tenemos que encontrar la forma de
balancear esta reacción con respecto a
las cargas agregando electrones por lo
que tiene sentido agregar por aquí dos
electrones
porque de esta forma obtenemos una carga
menos dos y pues ese es una forma de
hacerlo queremos que las cargas en la
izquierda sean iguales a las cargas en
la derecha ahora por otro lado sabemos
que vamos a tener algunos electrones por
aquí porque esta es la semi reacción de
oxidación ok y podemos recordar por ahí
que la pérdida de electrones es
oxidación y si estamos perdiendo
electrones los electrones tienen que
estar del lado del producto y listo por
el momento la semi reacción de oxidación
está semi reacción de aquí está
balanceada y ya nada más nos falta
terminar de balancear la semi reacción
de reducción
para la semi reacción de reducción
podemos recordar que la ganancia de
electrones es reducción y como estamos
ganando electrones sabemos que vamos a
tener que poner por aquí en el lado de
los reactivos algunos electrones ok
porque estamos ganando electrones lo que
sí necesitamos averiguar es cuántos
electrones necesitamos si es que
empecemos por aquí aquí tenemos 14
protones y los protones tienen una carga
positiva por lo cual tenemos 14 cargas
positivas y el anillo de cromato tiene
dos cargas negativas lo que le ponemos 2
- así es que del lado izquierdo del lado
de los reactivos tenemos 12 cargas
positivas en total del lado derecho del
lado de los productos tenemos aquí dos
iones de cromo
pero los iones de cromo tienen tres
cargas positivas y como tenemos dos de
esos iones de cromo
entonces tenemos 6 cargas positivas y
las moléculas de agua no nos aportan
ninguna carga entonces tengo 12 cargas
positivas del lado izquierdo y 6 cargas
positivas del lado derecho y lo que
tengo que hacer es agregar electrones
para balancear estas cargas yo ya sé que
se los tenemos que agregar del lado
izquierdo porque estamos en la semi
reacción de reducción en donde estamos
ganando electrones ok entonces los
electrones tienen que estar del lado
izquierdo del lado de los reactivos pero
además como aquí tengo 12 cargas
positivas sabemos que le tengo que
agregar 6 electrones para que en total
la suma de estas cargas nos dé 6 cargas
positivas y de esta forma ya balanceamos
la semi reacción de reducción
y listo ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es que el número de electrones en ambas
en mis reacciones sea el mismo
tenemos que hacer que el número de
electrones que le agregamos a nuestra
semi reacciones sea el mismo por acá en
la reacción de oxidación agregamos dos
electrones mientras que en la semi
reacción de reducción agregamos 6
electrones ahora estos dos números
tienen que ser iguales porque pues los
electrones que se pierden en la reacción
de oxidación son exactamente los mismos
que llegan a la reacción de reducción
aunque los electrones que se pierden en
la oxidación son los electrones que se
ganan en la reducción por eso es que
estos dos números tienen que ser iguales
y para hacer que estos dos números sean
iguales lo único que tenemos que hacer
es tomar toda la reacción de oxidación
y multiplicarlo por tres porque de esa
forma vamos a tener tres por dos o sea
seis electrones y entonces si el número
de electrones ya va a ser el mismo que
voy a borrar esto de aquí
y vamos a volver a escribir la semi
reacción de oxidación pero multiplicando
todo por 3 tenemos dos años es cloruro
pero lo estamos multiplicando por tres
entonces ahora tenemos seis uniones
cloruro y después tenemos aquí una
molécula de cloro pero como estamos
multiplicando por tres ahora tenemos
tres moléculas de cloro y tres por dos
electrones nos quedan seis electrones y
listo
ahora como tenemos aquí un montón de
cosas también voy a volver a escribir
nuestra semi reacción de reducción
tenemos 6
electrones más 14 protones más el anillo
de cromado con sus dos cargas negativas
y luego tenemos dos guiones de cromo
7 moléculas de agua y listo ya tenemos
nuestras dos semi reacciones balanceadas
y además ya hicimos que el número de
electrones que perdimos y ganamos sea el
mismo y entonces ya lo único que tenemos
que hacer es juntar estas 12 mil
reacciones y lo que obtenemos es nuestra
reacción redox balanceada
así es que pues podemos decir que ya
hicimos esta ya nada más nos falta
juntar las que lo vamos a hacer por aquí
entonces lo que voy a hacer es tomar
todos los reactivos tomar todos los
reactivos y ponerlos juntos tenemos 6 cl
- + 6 electrones más 14 protones más y
la unión de chrome pto
ok y luego ponemos del otro lado todos
los productos
que son tres claros
6 electrones más 2 millones de cromos
más 7 moléculas de agua y bueno creo que
para muchas personas es más fácil ver si
ya que tenemos las 12 mis reacciones
juntas es más fácil ver así que
realmente se cancelan los electrones por
aquí tenemos 6 electrones en los
reactivos y 6 electrones en los
productos entonces podemos simplemente
quitarlos y ya y ahora si tenemos la
respuesta final y tenemos la ecuación
redox balanceada
6 cl - +
14 protones más el avión vi cromato ok
y luego tenemos 3 cl 2 más 2 cromo
más las siete moléculas de agua y
esta es la ecuación balanceada ahora una
cosa muy padre acerca de las reacciones
redox es que siempre puedes checar tu
respuesta nuclear y para tener una
ecuación balanceada necesitas que esté
balanceada tanto en la cantidad de
átomos de cada cosa como en la cantidad
de cargas no crea y entonces vamos a
checar rápidamente que estemos bien por
aquí tenemos 6 átomos de cloro del lado
de los reactivos y del lado de los
productos tenemos 3 moléculas de cloro
pero cada una de las moléculas de cloro
tiene dos átomos de cloro entonces en
total tenemos 3 por 2 6 átomos de cloro
aunque hay vamos muy bien el cloro si
está balanceado del hidrógeno por aquí
tenemos 14 átomos de hidrógeno mientras
que del lado derecho tenemos 7 por 2 14
átomos de hidrógeno también de los
cromos tenemos 2 del lado izquierdo
y dos del lado derecho también del
oxígeno del lado izquierdo tenemos 7 y
del lado derecho tenemos estos siete así
es que todos los átomos están bien
balanceados y ahora ya nada más nos
falta checar que las cargas también
estén bien balanceadas lo que hoy por
aquí tenemos 6 cloros con una carga
negativa entonces tenemos menos 6
después tenemos que actuarse cargas
positivas voy a poner por aquí más 14 y
luego tenemos dos cargas negativas
y cuando sumamos esto nos queda 14 menos
8 que es más
así es que en total del lado izquierdo
tenemos una carga más 6 y del lado
derecho lo único que tiene carga es este
guión de cromo ok pero tenemos dos de
estos iones de cromo y tiene una carga
de más 3 así es que tenemos una carga de
más 6 y listo entonces está así es una
ecuación balanceada aunque hay porque
está balanceada con respecto a la
cantidad de átomos y con respecto a las
cargas así es que esta es una respuesta
correcta